how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this morning I woke up with a bunch of
people tweeting at me a bunch of people
deeming me about this new report that MJ
or Michelle Jones played by zendaya
is no longer going to be in spider-man 3
there's been a lot going around right
now about spider-man 3 nobody really
knows what's going to happen however we
do know that in this movie Peter Parker
is going to be on the run he's going to
be wanted and he's most likely going to
have to leave his friends and family
because they all know who Peter Parker
is so he'll most likely have to leave to
keep them all safe but we're going to
break down the support that says MJ may
no longer be with spider-man in the MCU
and talk about what all we know about
the upcoming spider-man film the
Infinity Gauntlet and G fuel winners
were chosen last night I announced them
in a video I'll link it up above so be
sure to check that out but I'm still
giving away an Xbox one or ps4 the
winner gets to decide I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers so be sure to
subscribe with notifications turned on
like the video and leave a comment down
below so this report is coming from
multiple different websites but it
actually isn't the first time that we've
heard this report this was actually
reported and rumored before spider-man
far from home came out and as we all
know Zendaya's Michelle Jones was
definitely in spider-man far from home
in fact she discovered spider-man's
identity as Peter Parker but what's to
become of her in spider-man 3 well like
I said it's been reported by multiple
websites this morning but I believe I've
tracked it down to a couple of the
original posters which are showbiz cheat
sheet and we got this covered
showbiz cheat sheet has actually been
saying since back in November that
Michelle Jones's and spider-mans romance
isn't going to survive the MCU and
according to today's report if this ends
up being true we may now possibly know
why today's report about Zendaya's MJ or
Michelle Jones leaving doesn't actually
mean that she's going to leave instead
this report simply states that Marvel
Studios is planning on introducing the
real MJ into spider-man 3 this report
says that a current early draft of the
script sees a more traditional Mary Jane
Watson
one more familiar to the readers of the
comics arriving at Peter's High School
and acting as a love interest for him
now this is a truly interesting report
one that may not be as far-fetched as it
seems MJ and Peter Parker are one of the
most famous comic book and
movie couples that exist in the
superhero universe but currently right
now the MCU has a different take on this
relationship as India's Michelle Jones
isn't a true MJ now when it was first
revealed at the end of spider-man
homecoming that Zendaya's Michelle Jones
was going to be the MJ of this
spider-man franchise a lot of fans were
really taken back and a lot of them
weren't really happy with the direction
that this franchise was going to go
involving MJ however since then and
since spider-man far from home has come
out a lot of people have truly come to
love and embrace Zendaya's Michelle
Jones or MJ so the odds of Marvel
Studios / Sony getting rid of Zendaya's
Michelle Jones's and Peter Parker's
relationship and the next spider-man
film is pretty slim however that doesn't
mean that they can't introduce a true
Mary Jane Watson into the next
spider-man film as a romantic conflict
after all it wouldn't be the first time
that they did that with the spider-man
film in the original spider-man 3 that
Sam Raimi did they threw in Gwen Stacy
as a romantic conflict with Peter Parker
and Mary Jane Watson so it seems like
this spider-man 3 may involve some of
the same aspects as the last one but if
this were to happen what would become of
Zendaya's Michelle Jones well there have
been some reports circulating around
since even before spider-man far from
home came out that Marvel Studios and
Sony plan on introducing either a spider
Gwen or a Spider Woman
now these rumors have been going on for
a while but honestly it wouldn't be that
hard to do
in fact Michelle Jones actually played a
pretty pivotal role in spider-man far
from home in helping Peter Parker
discover who Mysterio truly was and not
to mention that she figured out that
Peter Parker was spider-man simply by
paying attention to his disappearances
and whereabouts when all the chaos
happened in spider-man homecoming she's
very observant very analytical and very
brave she has everything that she needs
really to be a superhero the only thing
that would really need to happen is some
sort of a twist on how she could get
supernatural abilities right now it's
unclear on whether or not any of this is
going to happen however it won't be that
big of a surprise if Marvel Studios and
Sony decide to introduce a true Mary
Jane Watson into the MCU since we
haven't seen her on-screen in a very
long time now but let me know what you
think about
would you be interested in a true MJ
Mary Jane Watson coming into the MCU as
a romantic conflict between Peter Parker
and Michelle Jones or would you rather
Michelle Jones remain MJ for this
spider-man series let me know which one
you would prefer in the comments down
below don't forget to leave a like on
the video and subscribe but with the
notifications turned on that enters you
in my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a winner at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers don't forget to use co2
cosmic at G feel calm and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof